I can tell you a fun way some of you may
know about it it's called a friends
exercise uh which is really fun which is
go to a friend who you love and who
loves you um um the kind of friend that
if you called them at 3:00 in the
morning you know they would take your
call and if they called you you would
absolutely be there for them do not do
this with um a sibling do not just do
with a parent and do not do this with a
spouse it doesn't work um cuz they think
they know you um I go to a friend a
friend and and who who you love and ask
them this very simple
question why are we
friends and they're going to look at you
like you're crazy because you're asking
them to put into words a feeling and the
part of the brain that controls our
emotions doesn't control language so we
struggle and ironically you actually
stop asking the question why because the
question why elicits emotional responses
and you convert to a rational question
come on you'll say What specifically is
it about me
that I know that you would be there for
me no matter
what and they will struggle and they
will hem in the H and they go I don't
know and they'll start describing you H
you're trustworthy you're funny um
you're always there for me and you have
to play Devil's Advocate and you go
great that's the definition of a friend
What specifically is it about me then I
I know you'd be there for me no matter
what and they're going to go through a
few rounds of this you cannot help them
you cannot let anybody else help them
you have to let them go through the
stress and eventually after a bunch of
rounds they will give up and they will
stop describing you and they will start
talking about themselves and my friends
said to me Simon I don't know all I know
is I don't even have to talk to you I
can just sit in a room with you and I
feel inspired and I got goosebumps in
fact I'm getting them right now and uh
that's because they put into words
something that is deep inside of me and
will you know youve you're you're you're
there when you have the emotional
response to what they're describing
about themselves you will well up you
will have Goosebumps something will
happen and if you do this with multiple
friends you will get similar if not the
exact same answer because the thing you
give to the world your why is the reason
they love you it's the thing they want
in their life that fills that missing
Gap that they don't have which is why
we're not friends with everyone so it's
a wonderful wonderful way to to find
your why